osteoarthritis of the thumb also known
as basal joint arthritis is a problem
with the joint at the base of your thumb
smooth cartilage covering the bones in
your joint has worn away causing pain
and other symptoms
if non-surgical treatments don't work
your healthcare provider May advise you
to have a surgical procedure
one of the most common procedures for
this condition is called trapeziectomy
with ligament reconstruction and tendon
interposition
during this procedure your surgeon will
remove your arthritic trapezium bone
next your surgeon may replace this bone
with part of a nearby tendon
the tendon may be cut at one end and
passed through a hole drilled in your
thumb metacarpal bone
then it will be rolled up and put into
the space where the trapezium used to be
this tissue cushions your joint and
keeps the remaining bones separated
to find out more about this procedure or
other treatment options for
osteoarthritis of the thumb talk to your
health care provider